it is time to saddle up okay yeehaw
yeehaw a little yeehaw
national finals rodeo one of the largest
sporting events is back here in las
vegas ten straight days of rodeo
competitions at the tnm so nfr it is
already sold out that is not unusual of
course but there's a lot of other things
alongside nfr going on including hector
mejia live this morning on a horse
hector what's new this year
yeah a lot of things are new this year
and check out dave dave has been so
friendly today everyone let's give dave
a round of applause but it's time to
sadly say goodbye to dave so he can go
on and get ready for the day thank you
very much dave and joining us live we
have dirk to talk to us about the
competitions you were competing this
year for the first time tell us about
your role in that competition good
morning good morning i'm a steer
wrestler so i throw these lovely animals
down
they weigh about 525 pounds
i'm excited first time in vegas to
compete so in the whole process tell us
about your injuries oh man i've had a
lot have some peck injuries some knee
injuries i've been teeth knocked out so
definitely been some some morning
moments for the stairs a wild wild ride
for you but you were just telling me
it's definitely worth it oh yeah i mean
this is what we dream of as kids you
know i've watched uh television shows
and thomas and mack we're excited to be
here tell us about that excitement to be
in las vegas the competitions were in
texas last year you were telling me it
was just not the same oh man it's just
kind of boring not trying to be mean to
texas i love texas but it's not the
bright lights of vegas it's awesome
atmosphere here you can cut the tension
with the knife
it's exciting it's like the red carpet
gets rolled out for you guys which is
exciting oh yeah definitely i mean i
guess you can we know kind of how
celebrities are we get here during
the nfr and everybody sees a cowboy hat
and back number and they just love to
talk to you rightfully so welcome back
thank you for coming back to las vegas
and so it all starts today 10 straight
days of competitions 10 million dollars
in total in prize money so we'll be
covering this throughout the next 10
days for now reporting live hector mejia
and dirk taverner back to you guys live
local now good stuff hector thank you
very much looking forward and glad nfr
is back appreciate it